las críticas críticas si giran en torno
a los temas que ya hemos imaginado
especialmente al hecho de que el
gobierno de gabriel boris afirman no se
hace cargo del tema de la delincuencia
no actúa con la suficiente contundencia
en las calles también muchas críticas en
torno al decretado estado de excepción
en la araucanía en el sur es ha sido
decretado un estado de excepción acotado
es decir que sólo se establece para
regular por ejemplo la para que la
policía y las fuerzas armadas regulen el
tráfico pero no tengan otro tipo de
intervenciones borica había sido
contrario tradicionalmente durante la
campaña a decretar un estado de
excepción en el sur para la oposición el
gobierno no tiene una agenda marcada en
torno a los temas de seguridad que están
afectando mucho a los ciudadanos también
críticas en torno a la subida de los
precios y las medidas que está tomando
el gobierno al respecto y por supuesto
también qué ocurre si en el previsto de
salida previsto para el próximo 4 de
septiembre gana la opción del rechazo
eso también ha marcado como también
señala vais mucho la agenda
al empezar a evaluar qué ocurriría así
como dicen las encuestas se impone el
rechazo a una nueva constitución el 4 de
septiembre